ユーチューバーって
誰と恋したらいいと思うよこの空気を見る限り察してくれ
今日はオートな形だマジックで話そうぜまあ皆さんは多分様々な悩みがあると思います
その悩みを話せるばその一つとしてスペースがあると思います twitter とか
facebook とか google ぷらっしゅいんすたば員はみなさんご存知の
通り僕はね
ぶっちゃけ twitter しかほぼ使ってません気軽につぶやけるんですよね僕の
本名を言わなくても僕は twitter 楽しめてますし気軽な絡みでできるんで僕
は twitter をよく使ってます
ちょっと最近困りごとがありまして気になる金あるうちになったら感じ目の困りごとは
気になっちゃ勝ち
うざい本気で悩んだ時てね twitter とかで言わないんですよ僕のことを一方
的に知ってる人達の方が多いわけじゃないですかまあどっちかっていうとね reply
ちょうだいとか返事ちょうだいとかコメント改正とか無視すんなふざけんなバカにし
てるのか何で返さね大最低
みたいなコトタマ言われてしまうんですがツイッターだねやっぱりこうリアリティーが
ないですよ
twitter どっちかというとリアリティに欠けたじぇじぇねー
ただ僕は思っています本名を晒さなくていい by てのかもわからない相手が誰だか
わからないそんな状況で生み出される会はその中に果たして我々の本当の心の言葉は
あるのか
まあないとは言わないよないとは言わないし僕も思ったことさといい時もあります
真面目に答えてくれって言われるとそういうわけじゃない悪ふざけもあるしいたずらの
ようなコメントもある誹謗中傷 more
まあそれ
だけど
僕の相談には乗れない予定結論になっちゃうんすよ
twitter などちょっとゆるすぎるなっていうのと facebook だと
本名じゃないといけないとかあって僕のしてるリアルな友達にしか相談ができないと
いう弱点がない twitter facebook もうちょっと違うなと思いまし
て何か良い sa ねーじゃないかと思ったんですけども
もっと気軽に聞けるけどちょうどいい匿名性大
十段できるような衛星ですありましたそう皆さんご存知 mixi のコミュニティで
ございますまあ mixi 皆さん知ってると思うんですけども
もうね日本最大級のユーザー数を誇る冷静ねやって共通の趣味を持った人同士が
mixi コミュニティで釣っなかったり音楽からスポーツは芸能とかすっごいて戦で
コミュニティという場所がで270万個以上あるとか特徴です
twitter と facebook
mac の中間ってわけじゃないんですけど mixi な匿名性で結構真面目に答え
てくださる方も多いみたいなんて一つボケが相談したいトピックを作りましたでは実際
にその内容を見ていきましょう
頭を掻いてあげる僕のちょっと悩みというかがちな質問的な感じからちょっとマジで
聞きたいことがあるんで見てみましょう
こちらを
えっと内容がこういうものでございますあんまり恋愛の話ねぇクラウン
恥ずかしいな始めた妻が最近声についてのやっているらしい
彼女ができないこれからもずっとべきないのかなユーチューバーの本意について皆の
意見を聞きたいでござる
みんなで肇社長の悩みに答えてみようっていう内容になっているんですけどもまぁ
ちょっとまあちょっと聞いてくれよちょっと聞いてくれ
ユーチューバーが故意について流通盤ということがどんなものかと黒考えたんですよ
記事
方に難しいです結構月の話をすると正直も今日中
外歩けないんですよ mature 増えているとはもなんかいろんな方にありがたく
に声をかけていただいてちょっとばかりがタイヤそういうありがたい話じゃないや
感謝しておりますありがとうございますあれなんか話しがおかしくなってきた
で並べで時間があれば写真撮りたいと思った写真撮るんですけどもそれをしていると僕
の一日が終わっ
てしまったり予定がかなり狂ったりすることが結構あってその次も日中はほぼ外に出れ
ないんですよ
もし僕が外に彼女を連れて歩いていたとしたらその彼女みんな見るわけじゃないですか
なんかねやっぱ盗撮されるんでしょ
ドーナツそこもされてねもうちょっとも盗撮された時に俺のその彼女がもし映り込んで
たらその彼女ん
も盗撮されてて俺
別にねまぁ盗撮されてもいい
いやだよ俺もやだよ俺もいいんだけどハローズでジョイントしましょういやいやだけど
ね感じで良いとしましょうは俺がよくてもその可能性はどうなんだよおじさんは彼女が
一般の人だったんですよ
一般の人だったらなんかこうネットで買うとかされてマーニーなか卯ジャン何か言われ
たりするかもしれない
非常に悲しい俺はそんなので恋人を傷つけたくないんですよ
からね今一般の人と付き合っても普通にデートできる
のかなと思ってさんってなるとだよ一般の人とデートできなくなるといった次狙うとし
たら誰だユーチューバーがゲイの前はい
所13難しいとネット付きちゃえば僕は誰にも何も言われず平穏に暮らせるのかなと
思ってですね今回の悩みは僕竜ヶ岳の悩みじゃありませんユーチューバーの行為って
どうすればいいのっていう感じです彼女ができねえというか
ドーン付き合えばいいのかなってますできた時にね今回たくさんの方からコメントを
いただきましたちょっと読んでいきましょう
嘆いてるとできるものもできないまずは好きな人を見つけるまぁまぁそれはあると思う
んですよ
好きな人を見つけることは大事だと思うんですけど今だから言いましょうは僕が元カノ
と別れた何か原因的なものはあんまりうまくは言えないんですけどちょっと
youtube とかで酵素とにでになる
買ったでねそうだし買ったりして会う時間ができなかったというのは一つあります
好きだけでは同情もできない壁があることは僕は知ってるんでまぁ好きな人を見つける
というのは大事だと思うんですけど難しいところですよねありがとうございます肇社長
って名前なんですね子供がたまに映るで見てますありがとうございます
youtube で恋人募集を呼びかけたかどうですか好みの際人が言う
たら素敵な出会いに巡り会えるかも頑張って下さいなるほどそれはアリだな
下の動画で言われるから是非応募してくださいアタッカー
僕ですねあの女人にアタックが本当きていなくて基本ばじゃないとどうしようもでき
ないってちょっとヘタレなんですけどや俺セベれねーなーちょっとチキンだから攻めれ
ないよ
こういう感じでコメントがちゃんと登ります同郷ですが k 民生が保守的これ間違い
ないするタブ僕といえば県民なんですけどねくさいば県民よちょっと固いというか
分から言っ
地下にだからか知らないんですけど基本的にも守りの姿勢ですね皆が皆そういうわけで
はないんですけど直下を信じる
出会いを大切に私は彼氏がユーチューバーでも全然気にしないと思います逆に手伝い
たいです難しいの手伝わ0たくないのかもしれ
動画撮る時一人の世界に入っちゃうから一緒にいると逆にできなくなった場所おがー
多分彼女ができないけど一つだった方も
ファンに手を出すかまあアリだと思いますけど難しいですよね実機ファンだったかさん
はじめ社長とイメージてくるわけだってもし付き合ってが実際の初めはすごいバレー人
だったとか言われたら僕もたまったもんじゃないですよねそんなに現実と差はないと
思うんですけどちょっと怖いですよね
多分 youtube 撮影編集が楽しすぎて忙しくて女性
2日より部硬くなっているのでしょ
ある基本バタバタしてますそして空いている時間には遊漁ガストラ2をしていますまた
に俺の生活に入る余地ます
弾みにアトミックは眉山チェンジファンとの恋愛って言ってたから始めんがいいだろ
深いちょっと交流会して全然は広げる
僕動画 the めっちゃパリバで喋ってるんですけど超コミュ障で基本人としゃべる
のが苦手ですか返答が開いてももう枝ペコペコしてるだけでそのままは清掃がねはいと
いう感じでございました
まあ僕はトナー競ってないですよどんな人がいい
かなどういう付き合いかとしていけばいいかなと思います難しい子は僕ひとりで動画
撮りたいしちょっと一緒にいる時間を作りたいけど頭が編集したいしゲームをしたいし
カードゲームもしたい
100件以上のコメント本当に有難うございましたとても参考になりましたらでも僕も
いつかは結婚したいと思ってるんでね
結婚したらねお嫁さんと一緒に動画を撮りたいですね一緒にクッキング動画を撮って
子供と一緒に寝る動画を撮って女に成長の過程とかを見せたらなと思いますねあー妄想
が膨らんでしまったやすごいなんて家族で動画どんどんすっげー楽しいと思ってる
将来的
にそういうのが取れたら楽しいのかなって思ったりしています愛というでミクシィと
ビッグを使ってたくさんの意見をすることができました皆結構真面目に答えてくれてて
すごい参考になるのが多かったですの facebook だと本名だし友達にしか
聞けないからツイッターだとちょっとなんか軽い感じになって欲しいなぁみたいに思っ
てる人がいたらよかったら mixi 使ってみてくださいきっと真面目に答えて
くれる
でも入ると思いますではでは今後ですねユーチューバーはトピックを立てに来るら成果
が良かったらぜひチェックしてみてください以上肇社長の
ユーチューバーの恋の悩みでしたじゃん
ん